so Kanye went to the White House I
wonder if they tried to scare him into
not wearing his hat scared to not wear
this hat my own friends but this hat it
gives me it gives me power in a way I
love Hillary I love everyone right but
the campaign I was her just didn't make
me to know that the guy they didn't get
to see my dad all the time like a guy
that could play catch with his son there
was something about when I put this hat
off and make me feel like Superman
you made a Superman now that's my
favorite superhero and you made a
Superman cape for me and when the
president doesn't look good
America doesn't look good if he don't
look good we don't look good this is our
president he has to be the freshest the
flyest the fly explains the best
factories and we have to make our core
be in power we have to bring jobs into
America and we're putting people in
position to have to do illegal things to
end up in a cheapest Factory ever the
prison system I'll tell you what that
was pretty impressive well it's pretty
impressive because all we really have is
today all we really have is today we
just have today over and over and over
again the eternal returns of the hero's
journey and Trump is on his hero's
journey right now and he might have
expected to have a crazy like Kanye West
run up and support but best believe we
are going to make America great so just
another day in Trump world this really
is a new frontier full of incredible
allies and surreal surprises after being
told it was going to be the apocalypse
we have a booming economy ridiculously
low unemployment a new justice no big
ugly Wars progress in trade and peace is
breaking out among the Koreas and now
you have the world's biggest male
popstar going to the White House to
discuss big issues and getting what
seems to be a real concession you think
he would receive media complaint acclaim
for tryin you'd be wrong that but if you
think you're going to get a thoughtful
play-by-play and political analysis
you're not because that was an assault
on our White House
that was crazy such ridicule by those
who would never ever think of taking
such risks they call the event bonkers
and crazy dog whistles meant to bring up
Kanye's mental state sorry Steph if you
used mental illness as a disqualifying
factor to express opinion you'd have no
guests on your network so after today
expect a pile on SNL we'll do a skit
that will be much less entertaining than
the real thing
and the Mean Girls at CNN will call him
names like they did last night and he's
an attention [ __ ] like the president
he's all of a sudden now the the model
spokesperson he's the token negro of the
of the Trump administration here's some
advice when you know when you're on TV
giving a hot take in front of a
dwindling audience I'd hold off on the
accusations of attention-seeking but
West can handle it none of this bothers
him because he's on a mission and the
risk he's taking extending an olive
branch to someone that the media demands
he should condemn lifts him above and
beyond the abysmal groupthink
of the entertainment world especially
when he does this I love this guy right
here let me get
I love this guy right here yeah it's
really nice Jim Connie I appreciate it
so let's go have some lunch
let's go have some lunch why bother you
just ate the Democrats hey Jesse we were
talking about this there's something
actually very powerful it was just a
power I found it to be very powerful
yeah maybe I don't know it was a very
special moment just think about the raw
talent in that room Jim Brown one of the
greatest running backs ever Kanye West
one of the most talented artists of all
time and Donald Trump talented
politician and businessman all sitting
together and it was a real special
moment you played a really important
somebody and it was the soundbite where
Kanye said this because China has stolen
all of our factory jobs from the inner
cities and from the core of America it's
gotten to the point where young black
Americans are now taking risks and doing
illegal things to feed their family
because they don't have access to good
jobs on the streets anymore and they're
getting put in jail and if you can solve
that problem and if you can get on if
you can get black America buy into the
America first agenda to the made in
America agenda to the trade agenda to
the energy agenda that's going to have a
huge impact on this country where you
have people coming together of all
stripes of all stripes and fighting for
a nationalistic patriotic economic
agenda for this country it's really
special in the media already framing it
is negative they're saying this was an
angry rants when Taylor Swift or Katy
Perry they do these things there they're
called you know expressions soulful
expressions passionate you know you
don't hear that so you got to really
keep in mind that the media is trying to
trick your minds and I just thought
everybody needs to watch the raw of this
footage because it was even more than
you play it it was it was really
eye-opening yeah you want there was a
moment in there which I think you would
have admired which is he went in there
and and he complimented Donald Trump and
that he slipped in what he what he
believed was important that they had to
stop stop they have to stop stop and
frisk in Chicago because it's
destructive
look on Trump's face was like okay and
it was like so we so good actually he's
gay I mean you can laugh at him even
love me you can hate him but he's
actually got a concession I believe out
of Trump just by do I was gonna ask you
what concession so you think you think
the Trump now is gonna back off with a
stop-and-frisk I think that wit Trump
has gotten so much out of this and I
think there is a genuine affection
between these two men that he will
probably get something out of in
exchange for something else oh okay but
I didn't see any major concession on the
table because I didn't see any substance
instead what I see is a celebrity and by
the way I don't understand it i mean i
think that the oval office should be
treated with some respect and the idea
he goes in there and he's using such
awful language i don't think that's very
cool by bill clinton this is what we
heard from republicans but now with this
oh it's okay but here's the thing about
this guy I just don't understand why it
is that you know people would think this
is about the black community to the
contrary this is Trump I think speaking
to his white backers and saying I'm not
a race L comma oh here's this guy here's
Jerry West he's here with me so it all
doesn't make a change all these things
about me calling people dogs and coming
from [ __ ] countries and my don't
worry about it
here's so if a white person is actually
having a conversation with a black
leader your reason why it's always to
appease knowing racist Greg come on this
that this behavior by Trump didn't start
yesterday it's started remember he had
black people coming in like Jim Brown
like Steve Harvey remember this and
Kanye West
right over there Trump Tower one act and
again what came out of it zero so this
is the point oh this is this is the this
is called progress no this is progress
in terms of Trump scientists say you
know what forget Charlotte forget all
the things I've done
come on oh I have a black friend Kanye
West song he wanted to go to the White
House and talk to Trump and Trump said
no he would be labeled racist if Kanye
wants
the white house and talk to trump it
gets labeled racist you have to give
Kayne credit I don't always agree with
him sometimes I don't understand what
he's saying to be perfectly frank but he
goes in he speaks his mind and he knows
Kanye West knows that he's going to be
abused by everybody in Hollywood
everybody in his little bubble out there
they're gonna make fun of him they're
gonna be rate him and he doesn't care
and frankly that is inspirational
because in this time we should be
telling everybody if you have something
to say if you want to go and talk to the
President of the United States and have
the opportunity to do that even if you
don't agree with him on anything and you
can put policy issues on the table
whether it's stop and frisk or whatever
it is and you can bring look we're
talking about stop and frisk that's an
accomplishment because now everybody's
talking about it I don't think that when
you had this guy standing up there and
saying oh let's do away with the
Thirteenth Amendment which ended slavery
in this country you say yeah I think
something's wrong there was some
substance behind that that week we can't
touch on Dana but I do think that what
you are seeing is somebody who's willing
to sacrifice his his cool credentials
because he believes in it in the message
which yeah and the message is not a
single negative message in there well it
can be but when when you are in a
position where you have the freedom and
the financial security to be able to
like take a risk and do what you want
and you could be a leader in a different
way right so I'd also think that
everyone needs to just sleep on this
wake up in the morning and listen to
other people I mean one feels
passionately about it and I'm sure a lot
of people around the country do and I go
back to stop and frisk for just a moment
yeah yesterday president Trump was at
the International Association of Chiefs
of Police in Florida get over two days
ago
he loves the police he supports the
police he says his only administration
who's been behind you all that kind of
hyperbole but part of that is trusting
the police to do something Kanye West
Femina I like stop and frisk and friends
like okay you know what maybe then the
president because he has the power of
convening bring the two together because
what's really important is to be able to
have the two sides talk but stop and
frisk is not going to stop because
police think that is effective unless
you have a situation when it goes to
court the other day I mentioned this
about three weeks ago that Colin
Kaepernick should go to the White House
and meet with Trump and that was the
other thing that that Kanye West said
that like his
goal is to bring Kaepernick together
convening right and the other thing I
did think if I could say from just a
perspective is the this White House is
very television savvy yeah but once
sometimes they set up shots that do not
work for them right but and this one's
interesting president Trump's behind the
desk
yeah usually when he has a meeting with
somebody the Oval Office he's with a
world leader or somebody in there
sitting or like nikki Haley she was in
the two chairs over there the president
knew this wasn't the exactly
Jesus elevated level right he's like I'm
gonna sit behind the desk we're gonna
have a meeting and shot the way that
it's set up but Lloyd people that are
really in the shot you can see President
Trump a little bit the profile of Kanye
West and all the media yeah it was
actually very interesting to watch it
with the sound off yeah Heidi everyone's
getting hair and makeup done initially
cuz then you could just see them going
well this is the most crazy thing I've
ever seen then that crazy in a bad way
but just like it's different and if I
could just add one last thing we are in
a time of extraordinary economic
prosperity this is the time when you can
solve problems like the ones that
they're talking about this is where you
can beam people to be able to talk about
the square dot at we're not at each
other's throats for certain things when
you have peace and you have prosperity
you can deal with these things my tight
quote Scott Adams please he said it we
don't have a money problem we have an
ideas problem yeah all right drink
everybody gets a drink what Isis got out